the raft is secure but I can't reach
them over radio their comms must be down
what's your status already here
Yuriy I thought you said it was secure
it was let's go maybe it's not as bad as
it looks
I love the optimism but in my experience
when it looks bad it's usually worse
look out
[Music]
hold on
you okay yeah
welcome to the park just in time for the
fireworks
looks like we made parole boy electro
why is he letting everyone out I'll head
for the main control center and see how
bad the situation got it I'll go join
the party
everyone just quietly go back into your
cells and lock the door behind you like
fish in a barrel that doesn't sound good
oh hi RINO hope you like surprise spider
surprise what is he talking about
hey watch your status
me just trapped in a prison with every
criminal I put away in the last eight
years no biggie
electrum must be working for someone
this is too good to be true
scorpion can you hold on a minute I was
in the middle of a phone call and it was
business
don't let up lost you for a second there
you okay
nuts really electro rhino and now
scorpion are all on the loose what's
going on in the rest of the prison
camera system I'll give you a sitrep
soon okay I'll keep tracking elect bill
come on spider-man I thought this was a
shake
Gus stop this guy
[Music]
if you tell me who you're working for
I'll go easy on you can't stock it but
I'm flattered that you still try nobody
ever takes me up on that offer
but sir long time no see we're gonna
dance so much sorry no time to talk
okay I got the security cameras back
online how's it look well it looks like
the entire population of the route of
escape that makes the five of your worst
enemies that are now on the loose for a
second there I thought you were serious
I am serious I'd have to go some of them
are heading into the city this is nuts
keep chasing parties almost dark
[Music]
electro stop
how do you like my new suit dashing
where'd you get it it's an exclusive
club
[Music]
remember he said not to kill him
good idea in fact we don't have to do
this at all if you don't want to we
definitely want
[Music]
you
[Music]
you